You mentioned the various
types of accelerators
such as the proton-proton,
proton-electron,
electron-positron.
What are the differences
between those?
What will they do for you?
Quite apart from the technology,
what does the proton-proton
do for you as opposed to
electron-positron and so on?
Yeah, would you
like to take that?
Yeah.
OK, so is the mic on?
Yeah, OK.
I mean, in a way there isn't
really a dispute among those,
I think, because the
different facilities
that have been discussed
here have different pluses
and minuses in terms
of their ability
to attack new physics,
which is what we're really
trying to get at.
And so they're
complementary in many ways.
So, as Frank
correctly said, it's
easy to accelerate
protons compared
with electrons or
positrons in a big ring
because they don't
emit synchrotron
radiation in the same way
because they're much more
massive.
The problem is-- so you
can get proton beams
to very high energies.
But when you slam
protons into one another,
protons are not
elementary particles,
they're bags of
quarks and gluons.
And so a little
bit of one proton
will hit a little
bit of another proton
and they will scatter
from one another.
So although you have a
very high beam energies,
the energies of the
interacting particles
typically are very much lower
than the maximum beam energy
available because it's a
bit of one proton that's
hitting a bit of the other.
And then you have the rest of
the proton which causes a mess.
So, in fact, the
center of mass energy
of a proton-proton machine,
the effective center
of mass energy, is not
as high as the beam
energy written on the tin.
It's roughly an
order of magnitude
lower than the notional
twice the beam energies.
And then you have a
lot of background,
but you can get the beams to
really high energies using
that technique.
With electrons and
positrons there's
a fundamental point
like particles.
And so when an electron
and positron annihilate
you just get the energy.
That energy condenses
into the new things.
You know everything
about the collisions
because the momentum
is zero and you
can measure the energies
of the beams coming in.
And so you have complete
understanding of the kinematics
of these interactions.
And so when you make Higgs
particles, for example,
there's the Higgs boson and the
zed boson in the final state
and nothing else.
So from an experimental
point of view,
they're really quite
complementary ways
of attacking the physics.
And, of course, the physics
is the same for all of us.
It's the physics of top
quarks, Higgs boson,
dark matter, supersymmetry, or
whatever it may be out there.
So is that a sort
of a first clue
as to some of the differences
in what these things do,
the pluses and minuses of all
these different techniques.
So I sometimes say
with that as well
that the hadron
machines are kind
of discovery machines because
of that mix up of momentum.
You can get all kinds
of stuff flying out.
Whereas the electron and muon
machines may be more precision
machines, is that?
Another analogy, I don't
know if it's helpful,
is that these very high
energy proton-proton machines,
they're instruments which give
you a very broad field of view.
So there's a lot going on,
and you have a big landscape,
and you get a look
at the landscape.
And then when you've
realized that there's
a mountain in the distance
in the landscape, a Higgs
boson for example,
you want to home
in with a precision microscope.
And that's where an electron
positron machine is exactly
the instrument you want to make
Higgs bosons and nothing else.
Could I just-- could I make?
Yes, go ahead.
So this is absolutely
correct, of course.
Just two points to
pick up at the end.
So once you've
scanned the landscape,
it can be that the nature
that you're looking at
has a particle in it which has
a quantum number of an electron
as well as a quantum
number of a quark.
And that would be
a real motivation
for doing an electron
proton collider,
because you're putting
those two things together
and you see what comes out.
In the muon case you've
got one extra piece which
is that it makes neutrinos.
There isn't a theory that
describes the neutrino,
and therefore you are studying--
using the neutrinos directly
you are studying
physics which is not
described in the standard
theory, the standard model.
So you have a path
there that you can now
articulate where you can
start small and grow big.
So that's an extra piece.
OK.
Yep, there's a lot more
questions popping up.
I think this gentleman was first
if we can have the microphone
over to this side.
Thank you.
Yeah, thanks very much
for the great talks.
In the battle between the
linear and the circular collider
between Frank and Phil.
Complementary battle, which is--
Obviously there is a
technological barrier in terms
of the superconducting magnets.
Frank did mention it
in passing that there
has been some sort
of proof of concept,
but really that's not
completely sorted out yet.
And you will need--
there will be
need to be a technological
shift in the magnets
to get them to the higher,
to 100 kilometers in terms
of scale.
And I wonder whether
if, again Phil,
is the ILC ready, effectively,
technologically, ready to go?
Could we, apart from
funding, obviously,
are we ready to look at the
Higgs mechanism with that?
So, maybe I'll let Frank
address the magnet question
quickly first.
And then maybe Phil--
We are quite lucky
with the magnets
because we have the
high luminosity LHC
upgrade which I showed which
will come in the early 2020s.
And for that upgrade
we need about 40
superconducting magnets based
on the new technology already.
Not with 16 Tesla field,
but around 12 Tesla field.
So that will be a rather large
scale use of such magnets
already as the next
step of the LHC upgrade.
And that will be
the step that is
needed to go from there to
the production of thousands
of magnets for
the next collider.
But we will use several
tens of these magnets
in the upgrade of the LHC.
And that is an approved project.
And the prototypes,
they're working beautifully
with a peak field
above 12 Tesla.
So by the time that
project's done,
that technology is demonstrated
that that's ready, right?
Not at 16 Tesla, but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
But it's a new technology that
is demonstrated at 50% higher
fields than the LHC magnets.
So that's a very important
step in the evolution
to the next collider.
So about the technology
readiness of ILC?
We promised Suzie
that there would
be no fisticuffs on stage.
They promised me.
Not on camera.
So we will maintain that rule.
But you may have wondered about
the order of the presentations.
And they were, of course,
ordered in maturity.
[LAUGHTER] So that
is to say that--
Of the technology,
not the presenter.
The maturity of the
technology, not the maturity
of the speaker.
So the international linear
collider has a 10% scale
model prototype that is
sitting there in Hamburg
that has been built.
The technology
has been built in industry,
mainly European industry,
as a matter of fact.
It's not magnets
in this case, it's
the superconductor
niobium radio frequency
accelerating technologies,
the things that we
need to provide the 30
odd megavolts per meter
that Stuart introduced to
actually get the particles up
to high energies.
There are a hundred of these
modules sitting in a two
kilometer tunnel in Hamburg.
They'll be beaming that machine
by the end of this year.
That is roughly 1/16 of the
entire number of modules
that we would need to do the
real international linear
collider.
It's there.
It's ready to turn on.
It's a 10% scale model,
the technological issues
have been solved, the technology
has been industrialized.
So we really believe that
that is a shovel ready project
and we are waiting for
our Japanese colleagues,
hopefully, to give
the green light.
OK, there was another question
up the back on that side,
as well, over here.
Thank you for a very
interesting talk.
I've got two questions.
One, if muons are so
great, why not use taus?
Good question.
And two, the plasma thing,
can you actually get something
from one end to the other
without it hitting something
in the middle?
Or is that one of the problems?
Let's tackle those one
at a time, shall we?
So why not taus, Ken?
So the tau is heavier,
1.7 GeV or so,
compared to the muon
which has 106 MeV.
So it's an order of
magnitude or more different.
The rate of decay is going
at some power of the mass.
So the lifetime of a tau is way
smaller than it is of a muon.
And then because it's heavy it's
also more difficult to produce.
So you get a lower rate
when you produce them,
and they decay
more quickly, which
means that the intensity of
the beam decays more quickly.
So much, much harder.
There's one more disad--
so the advantages
you would get in the synchrotron
radiation all of that
would be better because
they are heavier.
The disadvantages,
because it's so heavy
it decays into all
sorts of things.
So you cannot do the neutrino
science with it because it
decays into too many things.
So you don't get the
clean [INAUDIBLE] beam
out of the tau.
OK, the second half of that
is, the question was, kind of,
can you get a beam
out of the thing
without ruining
your accelerator?
Is that, kind of, the question?
Yeah, I'm getting a nod.
Well, so you were talk-- maybe I
could paraphrase your question,
which is if we can make
something that's got a 10,000
megavolts per meter, why don't
I just make a meter long plasma
accelerator and--
We'll go on home.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
So there are some real
problems with that, actually.
Not problems, but-- one is-- so
the way that's been done so far
is to drive this, to create a
wave that the charged particles
can surf on inside the plasma.
And to do that you
need to, sort of,
send something
through the plasma
to create a wave in its wake.
That's why it's
called a wakefield,
it's traveling
behind the driver.
And so one of the
most successful ways
that that's been done so
far is using a laser pulse
to drive it.
Now, these relativistic
particles all
travel at basically
the speed of light.
So it's 99.9999% of
The problem with
a laser is as soon
as you put a light
which travels in vacuum
at the speed of light, as soon
as you put it into a medium
it travels a little bit slower
than the speed of light.
And so when I do that in a
laser plasma accelerator,
my driver is traveling a
little bit slower, maybe
99.9% of the speed of light.
So pretty close.
But that difference
between 99.9% 99.99999%
is enough that the electrons
are actually traveling faster
than the wave which goes at the
same speed as the laser pulse.
And so just like a
surfer on a water wave
starts at the top of the wave
and ends up at the bottom,
and once he's got
to the bottom he
can't gain any
more energy, that's
exactly what happens in a
laser driven plasma wave.
So we start at the
top of the potential
and we really drift down it.
And once we get to that point,
we can't get any more energy.
And so the maximum
energy that people
are getting per in a single
stage of acceleration
is limited by that process.
So that's why even though it's
10,000 megavolts per meter,
the limit is only 4 GeV in
less than 10 centimeters.
There are some ways
around this, there
are some really key
ways around this.
One of the most obvious ones
is you just build another one.
OK, so you got to 4
GeV in 10 centimeters.
Somehow you have
another laser pulse,
and you have another
10 centimeters,
and you get up to 8 GeV,
and you keep doing that.
So you can do that, and
you can look at the numbers
and still, as long as you
don't have too much space
in between these modules, then
your average accelerating rate
is still much better than
the conventional ones.
There are many issues with
that, many technical problems
with that as well.
Another way of doing this,
and this is quite cool,
I mentioned that we use lasers
to drive the plasma wave.
But the problem with a laser
is it travels a little bit less
than the speed of light.
But a charged particle beam
at a high enough energy
is traveling at
the speed of light.
And actually as a
charged particle beam,
if it's intense enough,
travels through a plasma,
it also drives this
wave, this plasma wave,
that will accelerate it.
And some very
successful experiments
have been done on SLAC
over the last 10 years
or so where they've used the
electron beam, and the positron
beam for some of
the experiments,
to drive a plasma
wave and accelerate
some particles from that.
And they've been doing
some great stuff.
One of the, sort of,
key headline results
happened a good
few years ago which
was where they took the--
before SLAC was turned
into an x-ray machine-- they
took the 40 GeV electron beam,
so it's gone all, it's got taken
two miles, it's got to 40 GeV,
then they put it into
a meter long plasma.
That beam drove a plasma wave.
Most of that beam slowed down
because it's energy was lost
into driving the plasma wave.
But right at the back
of the plasma wave,
the back of the beam was
sitting in the accelerating
part of the plasma wave,
and it doubled in energy
in a plasma that was
just a meter long.
So it took-- so really a few,
it wasn't a nice quality beam,
but it really demonstrated
that these plasma
waves have a huge potential.
So two miles to
get up to 40 GeV,
and another meter
to get up to 80 GeV.
And so I think, I would say,
I'm a laser wakefield guy,
that's what I
specialize in, but I
don't want to put
too much money on it,
but I think if you really
want to go for the high energy
frontiers, so the
particle colliders,
I think maybe the
beam driven stuff
has a bit of an edge on that.
Hopefully that was useful.
OK, thanks.
Are there more questions at
the moment coming from up here?
Yep, there's one right
at the back there.
Hi, thank you very
much for amazing talks.
I just had a question
for Professor Zimmerman.
Sorry, it's late.
You talk like accelerators
have expiry dates on them,
as in they only last a
certain amount of time
and then we have
to build a new one.
I was just wondering
why is that?
Does the technology
just become obsolete?
Or do they wear out and
become dangerous to use?
Or, yeah, sorry, it's probably
a stupid question, but--
Did you get the question?
Yeah, it's why the
accelerators have a lifetime.
Yes, so do they have a
physical lifetime, or is it
something else is the
reason why we are wanting
to continually build new ones?
To paraphrase your question.
I guess the physics
program ends at some point.
You deliver, you produce
a certain number of data
and you try to
increase the data rate
by improving the performance.
And at some point
you reach a limit
and then you are kind of
at the maximum performance.
For example, limit could be
the cooling of the accelerator,
of the IF power.
So you reach some
limit in intensity
and a limit in the data
rate that you can produce.
And then it becomes
uninteresting for the particle
physicists after awhile.
If you collect 10 years
of data, then running
another 10 years just
doubles the number of data,
so I guess it gives you,
in fact, a square root
in the statistics.
So at some point it
takes too much time
to improve the statistics.
At that point you like to
have another accelerator.
Either you improve the
performance by an upgrade,
like the high luminosity
LHC, it gives you
a factor of 10 in the
data rate so that you
can double the amount
of data in one year
or so instead of
waiting 10 years.
And then, in the
end we have seen
we have seen better get the
physics at that energy range
and we like to go
to higher energy.
It's more interesting for, at
least for the hadron collider,
it's more interesting to
go up in energy again.
When you go up in
energy you also
produce a lot more
events at low energy
because you have these
constituents of quarks
and gluons which collide.
By going up in energy you
also produce a lot more Higgs
particles, for example.
In fact some small
factor of energy
gives you one or two orders of
magnitude more Higgs particles
per second.
So you gain in the energy reach,
and you also gain at low energy
when you include.
I think Kevin was going to
jump in on that, as well--
There's also physical, by
the way, just to finish,
there's also a physical limit.
The collisions in the LHC,
in the large hadron collider,
are quite intense.
And after 10 years
or so we will have
destroyed the final
quadruples which
are hit by the debris
from the collision point.
So at that point we have to
replace these final quadruples,
and the idea is that we
replace them with better ones
to improve the performance
at the same time,
and not just build the old--
So there is kind of a
performance enhancing aspect
over time as you get
to know the machine,
but there are some physical
limitations as to how long.
There's also some
physical limitations.
And luckily they happen
at about the same time.
So we make an upgrade which
will give a higher data rate
and also will maintain the
functionality of the x-ray.
The message I get is
that it's primarily
driven by the particle
physics needs, what
the community actually wants
to look for in the data.
That would be your
main motivation.
I mean, otherwise--
Another limit, if
there is a competition.
Like I showed you the
Tevatron collider in Chicago,
it was turned off one year
after the LHC had turned
on because LHC was producing
at higher energy 10 times
more data and there was
no reason to continue
with the machine in Chicago.
So it was not
competitive anymore.
That could be another reason
to stop an accelerator.
The comment I wanted
to make-- so frank
is, of course, completely right.
However, the new thing
is often, or most often,
built on what has
been there before.
So the LHC, for example, reuses
the whole proton accelerator
complex at CERN starting with
the proton synchrotron, which
was one of the first machines,
and using the other things.
There are then limits
in operating those.
For example, the
technology is too old.
So we have the jewels in the
accelerator activity in the UK
that Stuart was mentioning
at Rutherford lab.
So ISIS, diamond, and
then of course the laser.
Also in the north of England
the Daresbury Laboratory
with the electron
accelerators there.
So ISIS actually is older,
no it's not older than me,
but it has been going
global for longer
than I have been
going in science.
And the early part of that is
now a problem of maintenance,
because the things are not being
built. So that's one reason,
those things have
to be upgraded if we
want to do the great science
that is coming out of there.
Can I pitch in at
this stage and say
one of the short films you
made in this accelerators
for humanity series that
Martin mentioned at the start
is actually about upgrading
that technology on ISIS.
So do check it out afterwards.
Sorry, continue.
So the other thing that
we have to look at,
and the kind of
things that Stuart
is doing as part of the solution
but not all of the solution,
is that the economics of doing
this science is changing.
And the copper and
the ways in which
we create the accelerating
fields are quite energy greedy.
They were created
in the '60s and '70s
when, perhaps, the cost of
electricity was different.
And so there's a
whole theme there
that we have to
get to grips with
to reduce the running
costs of those machines.
Really good point which has
spurred a whole lot more
questions, it would appear.
I didn't see who was
first, so I will come back
over this side I
think if someone
could run a microphone down.
Yes, thank you.
Yes, perhaps just taking
up that point on economics,
one of the great
improvements in technology
is obviously fusion reactors.
And part of the off spin
of what you are doing
is the technology to make
fusion reactors much better,
and then the cost of
electricity to everyone
goes down, of course.
We were listening to
a lecture about ITER,
I think, about
this time last year
and they were saying
fusion reactors are perhaps
20 years away.
Well, they've been
20, 25 years away
for the whole of my lifetime.
Is the technology
that, the engineering,
that goes behind the particle
physics and the expenditure
on that has got this
tremendous offshoot
to improve the engineering
of fusion reactors.
And I was wondering whether
the plasma one, in particular,
is an improvement on this.
So to me, just to interpret
that question, to me
the fusion reactors
and accelerators
are interrelated
physics, but sort
of a slightly different stream.
Would you like to
tackle that one, Stuart?
Yeah, can I have a go?
So, my quick question would
be-- well not question,
but my first
thought would be how
do particle accelerators
directly impact on fusion.
Well, there's a couple of ways.
So one is-- so in a fusion
reactor-- as a plasma physicist
as well as an acceleration
physicist I go to one or two
seminars on fusion, as well.
One of the things they do is
they fire a beam of particles
into a fusion reactor to
make the plasma spin around
and heat it.
And so, actually the very
large fusion reactor ITER
that's being built
in Bordeaux, there
is an equally large
neutral beam accelerator
next to it, which is
quite interesting.
Another thing that
particle accelerator
is going to impact
on fusion reactors
is there is-- in fusion you
have a huge amount of neutron
flux hitting the
walls of the chamber
and that gets damaged
because of radiation damage.
And so there are people
looking at new materials
to make the structures out of.
And actually there
is, there are plans,
I'm not sure where it's
going to happen or if,
but there's a machine called
IFMIF which is specifically
designed for testing materials
that are going to withstand
really high radiation
fluctuations inside something
like a fusion reactor.
So, yeah, there is a
crossover between those.
I can add maybe something.
Please do.
Also, we have a strong
correlation between CERN
and the ITER project, of
course, for cryogenics
and for the magnets.
Yeah, absolutely.
And, in fact, our
[INAUDIBLE] collider profits
from the magnet
development for ITER
because a superconductor
[INAUDIBLE]
was pushed for the
ITER fusion project.
And 600 tons that
was the first mass
production of the
[INAUDIBLE] superconducter
we want to use for the FCC.
So we're very lucky because now
these companies have produced
around the world
material for ITER,
and they are quite eager to now
join and produce superconducter
for the accelerators, also.
So we are lucky that we can
follow up on this production.
Great.
So there was-- sorry, I
don't recall if this person--
was there one up here before?
No, maybe it was
in the front here.
I'll get you next,
yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
Suppose-- this is a sort of
antiaccelerator question--
Oh, devil's advocate.
Suppose I said to you that
I could give you some higher
energy particles
without any accelerator.
No energy use, you don't
have to build anything,
you don't need to dig up half of
Switzerland to build anything.
But the only problem
is I can't tell you
where it's going to arrive.
So I'm talking
about cosmic rays.
I know you're going
to say statistics,
you won't get enough
of them, perhaps.
But we can get higher
energy and you could just
spend your money building
a big detector, perhaps.
Is cosmic rays giving
you higher energy now,
are they at all
useful in this regard?
So maybe Phil would you like to?
Thank you very much, Suzie.
You're welcome.
I'm instructing,
but I'm not meant
to be answering the
questions tonight.
Sorry.
That's OK.
So, without doubt the
most powerful accelerators
around are out there
in the universe.
We don't understand
how they work.
Probably plasmas.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, but they-- we can record
on Earth cosmic rays arriving
with incredible energies, I
think, what 10 to the-- I've
forgotten what
the power is, now.
16?
17?
You know, electron
volts, 10 with 16 zeros
volts equivalent of
accelerated beam energy.
And we don't really understand
how those particles are
accelerated out
there in processes
that are going on in
black holes, or whatever,
centers of galaxies, and so on.
But they certainly
arrive on Earth,
and there are detectors
on Earth which
measure the impact
of these cosmic rays.
And so what we can do
is we can count them.
OK, now that's
interesting at some level.
And you can make
a graph, you know,
of number of cosmic
rays versus energy.
And, you know, it
plummets down like this,
and you can see some interesting
features on the graph.
But it starts to become
very tricky when you get
to higher and higher energies.
Because the area of detectors
that you need to build in order
to be sensitive to
the highest energy
cosmic rays starts to become
tens of square kilometers.
And that's, sort of, the
size of the biggest arrays
that we have on
Earth at the moment.
They're of the order
of a few, 1 to 10,
square kilometers for
collecting information
from the cosmic
rays which basically
amounts to counting them.
I'm not saying that
isn't giving you
useful information about
the number of cosmic rays,
of high energy
that are coming in.
But that's not quite
the same as what
we try to do in accelerators
which is to make particles
in the lab, and measure
them in the lab,
and understand their properties
in microscopic detail.
So it's a really-- we're
limited in the energies
that we can do that by modern
technology, but what we can do
is make powerful and
incisive measurements
and really learn things at the
microscopic level about what's
happening.
It's a bit trickier
to sit on the ground
with a massive detector
counting these things coming in.
And what you measure,
of course, are the sort
of secondary and
tertiary products
of these things hitting
atoms in the high atmosphere
and spraying products
onto the ground.
So it's a bit harder to get at
this fundamental information
by counting particles
that are coming
in by mechanisms unknown
out there in the cosmos.
So it's not-- it's
very valuable science,
but it's telling you
things about astrophysics
and what's happening
in galaxies, and stars,
and energetic processes out
there in the universe more
than the microscopics of what
matter is actually made of
and what are the
forces that interact
between the building blocks.
So you could do it, but it would
give you different science,
is that?
It's complementary science.
The cosmic rays are
really telling you
about astrophysics, and
galaxies, and stars,
and black holes.
I think Ken, sorry, you were
going to pitch in at one point?
Yeah, well I, but Frank also
wanted to say something.
So was Frank.
If I member right, I think these
max, highest energy cosmic rays
of energy, one EEV
which is, I forgot,
is something like 10 to the 20.
I thought it was 10 to the 20.
Maybe it's 10 to the 20.
Yeah, it's a huge number.
And they cannot have higher,
I think this is limited
by interaction with the cosmic
microwave background scattering
in outer space.
But these particles,
when they hit the Earth
they hit some-- they can make
some reaction with a fixed
target on the Earth.
But the center of mass energy
in that collision, the energy
available to put to
new particles, I think,
is lower than the energy that
we have in the LHC proton proton
collisions.
I'm not sure that's true,
Frank, but never mind.
It's similar.
We can work it out.
It's not higher, no.
If they hit the proton energy--
If you've got a pen and paper
you can tell us at the end.
--10 to the 12th, right?
So, maybe it's
similar, it's similar.
It's not much higher.
And the rate is 10 to the
42 times-- of the flux-- 10
to the 42 times low.
Yeah, so you'd want to
build a new one, right,
so that you can get a higher--
With this I have
the ambition that we
will develop accelerators
which can reach the same energy
as a cosmic ray.
Yes, certainly that's
one of the goals.
We need 10, 8 orders of
magnitude to get there.
Maybe with the plasmas we make
a big jump in that direction.
With plasmas and crystals we can
get four orders of magnitude,
then there's only another
four orders missing
to reach the cosmic rays.
He's ambitions, isn't he.
Sorry, you were going to--
My comment was going
to be, actually
we are looking at the
cosmic ray sources.
So with the neutrinos there are
obviously three neutrinos, OK.
So that means
there are two gaps.
I've got three neutrinos,
I've got two gaps.
With the experiments
that I was talking about
you can measure the differences.
So we can tell that what
we call the second neutrino
is heavier than
the first, but we
don't know if the
third is heavier
or lighter than those two.
Those measurements that
are made with cosmic rays
can, in principle,
tell that difference.
So we are studying that.
It does have an impact on
the terrestrial accelerator
program.
The measurements that
Phil was talking about,
they are getting
really, really precise.
And if you look at the data
it is, over the last 20 years,
it has become precise
enough that the people are
doing sky surveys of where
these things are coming from.
They are trying to correlate the
different sources of particles
coming to the Earth, so
the optical astronomy,
and the cosmic ray astronomy,
and the neutrino astronomy,
and now of course
gravitational wave astronomy.
So that whole thing
is coming together.
We need to understand
the particles
so that the astro
part of our community
is able to understand
the universe.
And because the
universe is complicated
and we don't understand
it, it is not a priori
the best way to
study the particles.
So we have to use that beam, if
you want, where it is useful.
And we definitely do study that.
But then we need to make the
measurements of the details
that Phil was talking
about in order
to understand the
universe, which
is another fantastic goal.
Thank you.
So we had one more question
waiting just in here somewhere.
Yep, thanks, Martin.
The assembled
panel has talked us
through a number
of technologies.
But are there others not
represented here tonight
that it would be
interesting to know
about, perhaps work in Russia,
or Japan, or somewhere else.
Can the panel tell us
if there is something
that we are missing?
So I'm going to
address that to start
with saying that most of the
collaborations that are being
represented here are fully
international collaborations,
as Phil mentioned.
So I assembled the panel,
so I'm the one who,
sort of, chose which
panel members we had here.
Do any of you, would
anyone like to pitch in?
Is there anything
that you feel is--
As I said on
[INAUDIBLE], maybe that's
somewhere between the
conventional structure
and the plus, but in between
these micro structure
devices also driven by
lasers, potentially.
That's what I was
going to bring up.
OK.
So this is where-- lasers
have really, really
strong electric fields.
I was talking about the electric
fields in the plasma waves
I generate being
tens of thousands
of megavolts per meter.
But the electric
field in the laser
that we use to
generate it is actually
many teravolts per meter.
It's just it's not
pointing-- the laser
going in that direction,
the electric fields pointing
in that direction
and oscillating.
So you can't use it to
accelerate particles.
It just makes them wiggle
around up and down.
There is a way that you can
create, take some of that laser
field and make it point
in the forward direction,
in the direction
of the accelerator.
And that's by putting
it into a cavity.
So it's actually very
similar to the way
when you put a radio frequency
wave inside a cavity.
So if I have a radio wave
out in vacuum in free space,
it's also the electric field
is just pointing perpendicular
to the direction of
the waves traveling
and it won't do
any accelerating.
By putting it inside a cavity
which creates a boundary
effect, you actually get
an accelerating field
in the direction that you want.
And there is a technique which
is a dielectric acceleration
where you create very small
channels in a high damage
threshold piece of
glass, basically.
And that effectively channels
the-- it's like a cavity,
but for lasers.
So instead of using
radio frequency
you're using laser
frequency, but you're
getting a longitudinal thing.
I think there are other-- I
don't know a lot about it,
so I don't want to
talk too much about it,
but there are-- you could get
very high gradients, and things
like that, but you're
talking about accelerating
a few particles in
each channel at a time.
So it's not obvious how you turn
that into a high intensity beam
that you need for a big
particle accelerator, maybe.
We're not hiding
anything from you.
If it were easy, you
know, we'd already
have accelerators taking
us to the energies
of these cosmic rays
that are coming in.
It's intrinsically
very difficult.
And so I think,
with that exception,
I can't think of any other
revolutionary technology that's
out there that isn't actually
being represented on the panel
this evening.
It's very hard.
So that's probably a
good point to actually,
for me to just throw
in a question, which
is to say that most
of these projects now,
because we're talking
about big science
now-- well, apart
from maybe your lab.
A little bit smaller.
But very big projects,
usually rather expensive
projects, and
usually with interest
from all around the world,
so they're normally very big
international projects.
So I thought I might throw
the question at you of,
how do decisions get made in
this international community?
How does the structural
work of, you know, is it
the guy who shouts
the loudest who
gets their accelerator built?
Or maybe some of you
who are more involved
in that international decision
making process could comment.
Phil, do you?
I'm happy to start,
Suzie, thank you.
Particle physics
accelerator science
is genuinely a sort
of bottom up activity.
The community is not that
large, probably 20,000,
I would estimate,
particle physicists,
accelerator physicists
in the world.
That's a large number, but it's
still a well defined community.
There is genuine cooperation
in our community.
We genuinely-- I mean,
we've all worked together
over the decades, and so on.
So I would say that
fundamentally the discipline
is bottoms up.
People have good ideas.
They try and sell those
ideas to their colleagues.
You try and gather a team of
people to pursue these ideas.
You ask your funding
agency for some money
to support some R&D to
do experiments and push
technology, and so on.
If ideas look promising, bigger
international collaborations
form.
The one that I'm
privileged to lead
has been going for
about 15 years now.
We have 50 institutes from
around the world because people
think, people believe that this
is a technology that really
is very promising
and it's worth them
dedicating their
scientific lives
to trying to make it work.
And we've been able to achieve
funding for the project.
But, of course,
at some point you
have to move from
an R&D enterprise
to a real major facility that
is actually going to be built.
And those are, these days,
billion pound, dollar,
euro class facilities.
And that's where it becomes
a little bit more exciting,
because then the
world, of course,
cannot possibly afford to have--
if the money were unlimited,
we'd have all of these things.
We'd have electron positron,
proton proton, muons,
and a super duper plasma
wakefield accelerator.
These projects are now
of a sufficient scale
of technical complexity
and cost that it's
very difficult to
have more than one
or two running in the world.
And people come together
globally to collaborate,
to try to realize and
bring the resources
together to realize
multi-billion projects.
And they get spread out
over a long time scale.
That's why you saw
in Frank's slide,
I think, 20 years gestation
period for the Large Hadron
Collider.
And, hence, you've got to
run the thing for 20 years
in order to fully exploit
it, and get all of the data,
and all the information to make
that investment worthwhile.
So I think I'm straying from
the question now, Suzie.
Maybe I'll let somebody
else have a go.
But it's fundamentally
bottoms up.
And at some level you've
got to get serious,
and you've got to get
quite a lot of money.
And that's when politics, of
course, and global politics
starts to enter
into the picture.
So maybe we can continue
on that, actually,
about the politics and the
international community
of science.
There's been a lot of articles
and Information said about CERN
bringing together people
who might traditionally not
have worked together and how
that's had a positive effect.
And I know you've all worked in
very international communities.
So would any of you like
to comment on the, sort of,
positive aspects of the very
international cooperation
that happens in this field?
Maybe Ken, would you
like to comment on that?
Or disagree with the statement?
I don't disagree
with the statement.
So I think CERN is a very,
very special organization.
So it created in the '50s
when, obviously, Europe
was recovering after the war.
It's an international
treaty organization,
that's very special, I think.
To create the conditions in
which such a treaty could
be negotiated and signed you
would need special conditions.
And they existed.
The value of that is
seen across the world,
and CERN continues to
attract more countries.
And there's a negotiation period
there because they have to,
the treaty has to be agreed
by all the other members,
and there are, you have to
contribute to the budget,
and that's an international
treaty obligation
once you're a member.
So that brings in
inertia, because clearly
to get all the governments
to agree to a treaty change
takes time.
But it's robust.
Because with the
international treaty
comes some kind of
collective responsibility
of all those governments
that have signed it.
And that's why CERN is as
successful and as stable
as it is.
It is driven by science,
wants the best science
that can be done.
And that, actually, I think is
a unique combination of things.
The international
treaty organization
which is there to deliver
fundamental science.
That's a jewel in our collective
crown and we should protect it.
So, basically I agree.
Maybe I can add to that.
I think that especially
British accelerators have made
enormous contributions to CERN.
John Adams commissioned the PS,
and he built the SPS collider.
And then Lyn Evans
built the LHC.
So, actually Britain
has a proud history in--
Yeah, it was Mike Lamont is
leading the LHC operation.
It's just a wonderful,
wonderful collaboration
between the different nations
of Europe and around the world.
And it's working very
well, the system.
I think it's kind of a model
for successful international
cooperation.
Many people complain about
ITER and the fusion development
because it maybe looks
less successful and not so
efficient.
But the CERN model
is quite efficient.
Of course, we do live in
interesting times with regard
to European treaty organization.
But it is worth pointing out
that CERN predates the European
Union by three years.
And it's a completely
separate International treaty
organization.
And so we're often
asked, you know,
what does Brexit mean for the
UK's involvement with CERN.
Well, hopefully, to the extent
that Her Majesty's government
continues to pay
our subscription
to the international
organization,
we will continue to be
full members of CERN.
And as Frank has
very generously said,
play a very important role
in this greater entity.
So we've only got a
couple of minutes left.
So I'm going to ask
if there is maybe
one more question from the
audience before I wind up.
Is there one more going?
There's one right up the
back in the middle, I think.
If I can, you're
just below a light,
so that was very
difficult to see.
There we go.
Hello there, I was wondering,
you know for electron colliders
you have the electron
and positron colliders.
Is there any muon-antigluon
or tau-antiatu colliders
that exist?
And if there are, is it perhaps
influential in discovery
for a new powerful
collider, for instance?
So, do any muon colliders exist?
No they don't.
So people have made muon
beams, many, many muon
beams around the world, a muon
beam at Rutherford Appleton
Laboratory, for example.
The difficulty is making
the beams intense enough.
So I had a slide which was
intense cold muon beams, cold
is a jargon for this small beam.
So if you want to get
collisions at a large rate,
you have to have either an
enormous number of particles,
or you bring them into
a tiny, tiny spot.
So both ILC, CLIC, FCC,
they all make the particles
into a tiny, tiny spot.
So to do the
neutrino science, you
need a cucumber of particles.
If you want a muon
collider, you've
got to have something less
than the thickness of a hair.
That's the size of the
beam that has to collide.
So the difficulty
is that you have
to reduce the size
of the beam such
that you can get
enough collisions.
And that's what this
cooling business is about
that we're building the
experiment at Rutherford Lab.
And we need to demonstrate
that technology,
and then we can discuss
making the muon collider.
OK, so I have one final
question for each of you
just before we leave
which is for the younger
people in the audience
tonight, or for those
who are particularly
interested in this field,
do you have any
advice for people
who might be
interested in working
on these future machines that
might come along in very soon,
or 10, 20 years time,
40, 50 years time?
Any sage words of
advice before we go?
I'm going to start on this end.
Well, I'm sorry, the
trite answer in the UK
is, of course, that you've
got to do physics at a level.
And especially if you are a
female member of the audience,
we desperately want you
to do physics at a level.
And I can see there's a
budding accelerator physicist
on the front row here.
Yeah, physics at a level.
Go and do your physics degree.
Go and get a summer intern
at CERN, for example,
and go and spend eight or
10 weeks during your summer
vacation working on
a project at CERN.
Get excitement.
Get fired up.
And then come to the John Adams
Institute and do your PhD.
Frank, anything to add to that?
Yeah, I'm doing accelerator
physics in 27 years, or so.
I did my diplomacies,
and then PhD,
and I already studied with
accelerators and colliders.
And I enjoyed very much that
you can do all kinds of things.
You can be in the control
room playing with the beam,
and optimizing the operation.
Can I just check,
do you actually
get to control the LHC?
Is that part of your job?
Not at the moment any more.
But you have?
In the past, yes.
How cool is that?
Sorry, I get jealous.
For some experiments we
can control the LHC, yes.
So it's fun career?
Yeah, you can do
computer simulations.
I do a lot of
You can do analytical
calculations
and you are more or
less free to choose.
And I like the combination,
it never gets boring.
I can spend some day
in the control room
with the operators, I
can spend another day
in my office doing simulations,
or you can have meetings,
or whatever.
But you can do many
different things.
You are more flexible than
many other fields of physics,
I think.
And we need a lot, we need
more accelerator physicists.
We have never enough applicants
for doctoral students,
or for post docs.
We never find candidates.
We have many more
posts than applicants.
So anybody--
OK, if you want a job
at CERN, now you know.
I must say, yeah,
it's very difficult.
They're oversubscribed.
Last year the post docs
were oversubscribed
by a factor of 10, or so.
10 different groups asked
for the same candidate
because there are
so few candidates.
So that's why FCC is not faster,
because we cannot get all
the post docs that we need.
So we need smart people.
And then maybe also, maybe the
time scale is a bit worrying.
You don't want to wait 20
years for the next machine
accelerator.
But I enjoyed very
much, I can always
work on an operating machine,
work on the next generation,
and also look at the
generation beyond the next.
So I like this very much.
And you can learn, you always
learn from the existing machine
what to improve and what to
do better for the next one.
Long term, long term view.
You can do the things
at the same time.
Yeah, that's a good
point, actually.
Anything to add over this side?
I might just have
one thing, sorry.
Yeah, go ahead.
Which is that, so one of the
good things about doing plasma
based acceleration certainly
is, as a PhD student,
is the time scale of the
way things are moving
is much faster and the
experiments are much smaller.
So you almost get
to own a large part
of the project all of your own.
Whereas if you get involved
in very big machines
you can be very, very focused on
a really important part that's
making a big contribution
to something very important,
but it can be kept
very detailed.
Whereas I think when you're
doing the plasma based stuff
it's quite fun because
you do everything
from building the machine, to
designing it with simulations,
to doing all of the
data analysis and stuff
all on your own.
So it's kind of fun
like that as well.
And not to be left out,
Ken, anything to add?
So I've been thinking, so
this it's-- I'm going to say
something which is personal,
which I never really do.
I have two daughters,
one of whom
is genuinely considering
particle physics.
And therefore this is
a real question for me
not an academic question.
And what I say to her
is follow your heart.
And I've had a
great time, right,
I've never done a
day's work in my life.
What I do beats working
for a living, really great.
If she falls in love with
another area, follow that.
Because that's what
will make you work.
Particle physics, accelerator
science is fantastic.
If you love something
else, do that.
I think that's a
nice point to end on.
Do what makes you happy.
And I think for the panel down
here working on accelerators
has made us all, given us all
a really enjoyable career.
I'm obviously just starting out
in my career in accelerators,
and I certainly enjoy it
for many of the elements
that you've said.
So just to wind up
I'd like you all
to please give a massive
round of applause
to my illustrious panel.
Thank you.